affaire grégory depuis que le président
simon a pris en main l'instruction on se
prenait à espérer que trois ans après
les faits la vérité allait bientôt
éclater aujourd'hui le magistrat a
procédé au bord de la vologne à la
reconstitution des conditions dans
lesquelles le corps de grégory a été
jeté dans la rivière didier pouillot fr3
lorraine la montagne a accouché d'une
souris par trois fois le mannequin
spécialement préparé pour l'occasion a
été jeté dans la vologne toutes les
précautions avaient pourtant été prise
ils étaient munis de bras de jambes
était habillée d'un pantalon d'un
blouson de chaussures et d'un bonnet
toutes les conditions requises pour
qu'il représente le mieux possible le
corps de grégory ça n'a pas été
suffisant par trois fois ce mannequin a
coulé immédiatement ou après avoir
parcouru quelques dizaines de mètres est
ce que l'expérience se déroule près du
passage à niveau en amont de celle où
près du barrage à l'entrée du village
concluant pour les avocats de la défense
ces résultats ont cependant été
contestée par les avocats de la partie
civile déjà sceptiques quant aux
conditions de cette expérience ils ne
m'ont convaincu qu'il y avait de grandes
difficultés a estimé analogues le corps
d'un être humain et puis une substance
inerte si bien reconstituée soit elle
par rapport à corps humain placé devant
cette nouvelle polémique qui répondant à
la demande de la partie civile le
président simon a utilisé un deuxième
mannequins sans bras ni jambes plus
légers celui ci a flotté sans problème
mais s'il a franchi les obstacles de la
vologne il en a également enregistré les
traces jeté depuis le passage à niveau
depuis le barrage où depuis l'affluent
de la vologne ce deuxième mannequin aura
finalement servi à tester les différents
endroits susceptibles d'être considérés
comme les lieux du crime mais le
président simon pourra-t-il en tirer des
conclusions qui ne soient pas contestées
par l'une ou l'autre des parties à la
fin de cette journée les interprétations
de la défense et de la partie civile est
radicalement opposé les certitudes que
le magistrat était venu chercher son
enclos loin d'être établie et le sort de
christine et jean marie villemin qui
sont restés toute la journée à la mairie
de sel est loin d'être scellé